hello good morning my name is Adam Smith
calling from nobelprize.org
congratulations yes you're going to be
bombarded from this point on crazy I'm
not quite sure but it almost seemed a
little unreal having not actually heard
from the committee so you you're hearing
it you know you know about these things
and you can really happen it's hard to
remember how things were thirty years
ago
and nowadays the idea of thinking genes
with behavior is sort of accept people
expect expect that but then it was a
very pioneering thing to do oh yeah I
mean this was you know I had gone to
Stanford to learn how to use this
technology it was brand-new in the
seventies and starting up my lab but
Rockefeller I had I had worked a little
bit on this problem circadian rhythms
and I just thought it was a terrific
problem and they need the toughest thing
I could try to tackle because it was
behave what what what could we learn
about a fairly complicated behavior we
all exhibit which was you know most
easily represented by sleep-wake cycles
and frankly I thought we'd find out
maybe a little bit I never thought we
would really understand what that motor
fine this was at the time we were very
lucky we managed to find jeans that fit
together like puzzle pieces to explain
another thing work and and the
techniques and the approaches kept
changing and I kept I was very lucky I
kept getting students and postdocs that
were extremely good and and just get
everything right and the other piece of
this was you know sort of a race going
on in the early years my colleagues Jeff
Hall and Michael Ross - and we kind of
pushed each other along because I mean
most of it most of it was independently
done but we did it to collaborate from
time to time but we work on slightly
different problems with the solutions
for those problems all right worsening
fit together like puzzle pieces to kind
of bring the picture interview it's been
really quite satisfying this is you know
this this really pushes it way way over
the top
yes it's really quite incredible you you
do sound wonderfully amazed it's very
nice to hear oh I am I'm just I'm just
like eh I think I said I'm just
wondering how I'm gonna get for you
today we will be seeing you in Stockholm
in December of course
[Laughter]